hello I'm Tommy so I'm going to talk
today about a a real project that we had
in petaca and it deals with the zero
inflated continuous aggression and just
a few words about us so about me more
than four years in a platica a lot of
experience in financial markets algo
trading I guess you will be surprised
how much doing analysis in financial
markets can be fruitful in working with
behavioral analysis just a comment and
pure mathematics background and I will
team so basically I walk in a House of
fun which is one of the studios in
platica building a number of studios so
we are a team of 35 data scientists and
authoring solutions to nearly all
departments product marketing economy
VIP and they working closely with data
engineering of course the BI be a DevOps
some of the tools that we are using
indicated there suppose we want to
predict some numerical value in which we
know that has a very specific shape this
is what we call a zero inflated chain so
you have a mass probability in zero and
other values of positive values so we
cannot really change or transform this
distribution into something that looks
more Gaussian so what could we do
specific examples that we faced dealing
with this problem and so let's assume
that we want to predict the total
deposits of a user so we know that we
are in critical we are a freemium game
so most of the players are not positive
players so some examples of
cases is for example marketing campaigns
we are spending a lot of money on
campaigns to bring new players to our
app and we would like to be able to say
about campaigns whether they are good or
not so good can be regarded as linked to
engagement but of course we are
interested in revenues so we would like
to know whether a campaign is good
meaning that we will let see revenue for
such campaign or not so maybe we can
terminate a campaign stop a campaign or
maybe even enhancing and get it to run
Lauren Logan time and another aspect is
for our VIP with users so we have our
VIP managers dealing with those users
they would like to know whether some of
the users will have some regression in
the depositing patterns so this is very
important so what we can do we're trying
to tackle this issue so we can they go
plain regression like deep architectural
maybe some boosting and we can use
two-step models so we can try and
classify at the first step without the
users that are going to pay and run a
regress regression model on those
positively predicted users so we know
and the data supports that that we have
a major imbalance issue with data so
this classification can be quite
challenging and not speaking of on the
regression that we follow just a comment
so michelle will talk about imbalance
using deep and geometrical methods auto
account and stuff so stay tuned and we
can try even predict the number of
future transactions using something like
Poisson regression
and then once having a prediction for
the number of such transactions just
multiply this by something that
characterizes the users specific
transaction like on average some
weighted moving average or something
like that maybe we can go based on
having a bio on the output maybe we can
use that or some other dip architecture
we have work in progress dealing with
multi task neural networks so still
inputs so what we'll discuss today is
the tweety distribution pre distribution
it has as you see it shares the
following characteristics we have a
linkage between the variance and the
expectation given in this formula and
actually 20 distribution is a
generalization of more known
distributions like the Gaussian the
pores on the gamma or Sonnen gamma you
see here or so on gamma and this is
dictated by the P which is the power
that is implied to the expected value
there are other values three and more
that relates to a more in satiric or
less known but we are mainly concerned
with the compound pairs on gamma which
deals with the power which is in the
range of 1 & 2 so having the P in the
range of a 1 & 2 we get the compound
poisson gamma distribution so it is
actually nice it's like having a random
variable which you can present as a sum
of a specific number of gamma random
variables but the number of such gamma
the random variables is dicta
by a possum so assuming we are dealing
with deposits we can have the T T
they're being given by a result of a
possum insta bution and once we have the
number of transactions which is d every
such transaction can be represented as a
gamma distributed we have several
connections between the parameters even
here now as we have seen the P kind of
controls the shape of this distribution
as we will see here so you can get some
sometimes very crazy such shapes of
distribution and for example this one
this is more of a Poisson like we
mentioned the P is equal to 1
also we have another parameter which is
the dispersion that controls the shape
here it relates to more variance as you
see now the thing is the question is
whether we know if we know something
about the target distribution whether
this can help with the prediction so we
know that we are running some deep
architectures to deal with regressions
but here we actually know something
which is very special about the target
distribution and it's its shape so we
want to be able to apply some model that
can deal with this distribution so
actually this area of using this
distribution came for me actually for
insurance predicting the number or end
the the absolute value of claims
this is like one of the resource of
sources of those say and academic work
that was done one implementation is due
to these guys and that they have built a
tree boosted algorithm and the
difference between or we can say the
addition that we have in this algorithm
is the loss function that takes into
account their likelihood of this special
distribution so just to present one test
case in which we have applied this modem
so we wanted to predict the next 30 days
total revenues for users and those are
already deposit all users so we did not
try to predict whether they will convert
they will deposit for the first time and
we know that substantial number of such
users and will not deposit so this is
why we used it with the regression and
we have in this model several dozens of
fischels
some related logins engagement some
relates to deposits at plane activity
all sorts of features that we have
extracted and additional guidance to the
model we try to help the model in part
by pre segmenting our population into
five parts the reason for that is to
have our models running on more
homogeneous set of users and each of the
groups also shared this Twitter
distribution so it makes things much
friendlier and we were running different
models for different segments of course
so we took the extra boost linear
regression as a baseline so we all know
that the boost
usually gives us good results sometimes
even
very good results so the competing model
was actually boost but using the Tweedy
as the distribution so the call was to
see whether having my own knowledge of
on the distribution can make a
difference so moving to the model
performance first just for today an
aggregated evaluation matrix we have the
mean absolute arrow and read through to
him mean square mean average deviation
so we just see that on aggregate at
level the tweedy did better so maybe not
you know we see like ninety percent but
in any case she did better on an
aggregated level one thing which is
important to notice is that the
difference between the zero percentage
or the proportion of zeros in each of
those groups so we see that it can rage
for nearly 95 percent in Group A to
somewhere within the 10 percent in Group
E if we move to a finer analysis of the
results we would like to see so first we
have the predicted minus actual divided
by the actual this is like the arrow but
not an absolute value of the arrow
divided by the actual we would like to
have this value equal to 0 to say that
we have an ideal model so what you see
here this is like the zero line and
again we would like to have all the
predictions giving us 0 but of course
this is in ideal world
so we have the tweedy in green and the
regular in red we see that in group a
which suffers fall from the most severe
imbalance issue that the Tweedy
is doing much better and as we go along
those groups in which we have seen that
the zero proportion gets to be evil may
be negligible we see that the difference
is very minor if if at all so we see the
effect of the Tweedy regression knowing
that the distribution requires something
like the Tweety I didn't mention that
but he'll of course I cannot really
divide by actual for all the users I
only divided that for the users that
quote positive predicted values sorry
positive actions so what about those
users that had actual zero values we
mentioned that the Tweety should handle
that so we as we see it we would like to
see that
knowing that user did not deposit the
model should reflect that and this is
what we see he'll having the ratio of
the Tweety predictions and the regular
predictions and we have this ratio which
is less than one in all the cases but
significantly small for the group with
very small number of positive values so
it handles this in a very good way so to
conclude if we want to predict zero
inflated target knowing that can help by
using this M Tweety regression or other
distribution and the world zeros in
output degraded Tweety regressions
effect so it really shines when we have
more zeros now using boosting methods
something that we it is very common
nowadays and we will only
running the people a metal is one of the
parameters but all the other parameters
were optimized using any other way you
know whether this is Bayesian or other
and some implementations that exists of
course the extra poles the no next
oppose we have h2 all that allows you to
use GLM's as well as deep dense networks
with the tweety distribution we have
light CPM we have several packages for
our and python and spark also allows you
to run
GLM models using the 3d distribution so
walking as we are now walking on
different architecture of deep neural
networks still walking ports that's it
[Applause]
[Music]